bonjour c'est à vous bonjour david
douillet bonjour excusez moi là d'un
problème technique
ça me permet de poser la première
question sur nicolas sarkozy
hier soir les soutiens les membres de
l'association de soutien à l'action
nicolas sarkozy ont reçu un mail de
votre part david douillet qui commence
ainsi je continue à me battre pour la
france et c'est pour cela que j'ai
choisi de m'engager au côté nicolas
sarkozy rejoignez nous est ce que ça
veut dire qu'il ya une accélération dans
le mouvement qui va vers la candidature
j'espère bien de nicolas sarkozy mais il
faut qu'ils feront pas il faut regarder
on est bien oui on est pressé par
ailleurs mais le démarrage de la
primaire le dépôt des contraintes de la
candidature le nombre de parlementaires
de signatures les 2006 9 septembre début
septembre il ya l'été qui au milieu de
tout ça il faut déjà parce que moi je
vais l'appeler à se présenter dès
aujourd'hui ah mais oui dément fin le
plus rapidement possible parce qu'on en
a besoin
et moi j'avais trop grande dans l'arène
rapidement mais rapidement avant l'été
j'espère ouais j'espère maintenant vous
lui montrez lui avait il dit il a évolué
daniel respectifs à saint louis
et comme je l'avais dit en en 2012 qui
dès pour qu'il démarre un peu plus tôt
au moins autant que le retard à l'époque
selon vous je le pense oui il faut pas
reproduire c'est très exactement
d'accord alors s'il n'est pas encore
candidat il se nicolas sarkozy ne se
prive pas pour autant de de cibler ses
adversaires ses futurs adversaires à la
primaire que dit il par exemple sur sur
juppé on peut tout dire mais pas qu'il a
du talent qu'est ce qu'il dit sur fion
il n'a pas d'idées pas d'originalité
est-ce que l' attaque frontale c'est la
bonne stratégie blabla je me suis
toujours étonné de ces mots de ces
phrases qui reviennent comme ça qui
surgissent de nulle part qui sont
peut-être sorti d'un contexte il l'a dit
dans l'avion de dans le retour de
l'avion de new delhi à une journaliste
du point qu'il a été la retranscription
moi je suis toujours méfiante c'est
affaire j'ai moi même été victime de
phrases sorties de contexte soit dans un
livre ou autre chose je suis toujours
méfiant
tout ce que je sais c'est ce que j'ai
vécu au sein d'un gouvernement avec lui
et y compris avec alain juppé lorsque je
suis rentré au ministère des affaires
étrangères comme secrétaire d'état on a
là des hommes de grande qualité
voilà je vous le dis on a cette chance
c'est quand même incroyable tant mieux
des hommes d'état voilà moi je considère
que mes amis ma tension qui s'installent
autour de nos mauvais que ça ça c'est ça
c'est des vues c'est un climat qui n'est
pas négatif c'est ça que je veux vous
faire comprendre concurrentiel mais la
négative oui c'est ça c'est normal c'est
de la concurrence et c'est normal et de
cette concurrence et c'est moi le seul
avantage que j'espère tirer enfin que
pour notre groupe de cette primaire
c'est qui est une émulation des idées
des talents voilà ce qu'ils ont tous du
talent et et si la raison pour laquelle
je suis nicolas sarkozy sait que ce
talent il nous l'a déjà montré est que
ce talent là
la première chose à mon sens ce qui
devrait faire c'est que on en aura
besoin grandement de son poids de son
envergure politique à l'échelle de
l'europe parce qu'il faut d'abord régler
ce problème de l'europe avant de
s'attacher à nos problèmes nationaux
autre phrase rapportée de nicolas
sarkozy toujours dans le point ce
monsieur trump donc donald trump le
candidat républicain à l'élection
américaine est réussie parce qu'il ne se
refuse aucune outrance assez nicolas 4
sarkozy qu'il dit est ce que ce ça peut
être un modèle noir nicolas sark de nos
sûr que l'on n'est pas aux états unis
vous verrez c'est enfin je pense un
point ne sera pas élu je trempe que
trump a changé complètement d'attitude
il va plus être aussi provocateur il va
rentrer dans le rang il va flatter les
gens qui sont très conservateur et très
frileux et vous verrez que il arrêtera
d'être dans un populisme exacerbé la
question lors d'une récente visite dans
l'euro nicolas sarkozy a indiqué que
laurent wauquiez ferait probablement
l'intérim lorsqu'il sera candidat à la
primaire l'intérim à la présidence du
parti
est ce que il est suffisamment
rassembleur pour cela dans une période
où justement le rap le parti aura besoin
de se réunir
c'est la partie moi je remercie nicolas
sarkozy et c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles je le suis d'avoir su refaire
un parti on est reparti de zéro en
réalité après le cataclysme
copé fillon il a reconstruit il a
rassemblé les gens ils à désendetter un
parti il a remis un projet en route un
projet d'opposition en route
bref il a fait le job ou quoi et c'est
juste formidable laurent wauquiez peu
qu'il peut continuer ce job là il savait
quand expliquant quand même au sein du
parti a beaucoup en général chacun a du
caractère et très mieux parce que nous
arrivons tant vous savez j'ai deux
groupes en général c'est quand les voix
sont tracés quand on a posé les les
lignes de la ligne de chemin de fer
quand on met le train dessus nicolas
sarkozy a à construire la ligne d un
public 1 et et laurent ne sera que la
locomotive continuera à voguer dans mon
sens c'est noté merci beaucoup merci
merci david douillet d'avoir fait la
semaine avec nous